the road to me is very representative of  how I approach my life but I believe  that you're able to create your own path  and your own life and achieve everything  you want regardless of what society or  people tell you it's taught me pretty  much everything you know when you get to  experience other cultures and other ways  of life it really gives you the chance  to gain perspective and appreciation for  where you came from the city to me it's  everything it has a lifeblood of its own  and the energy is palpable it's  something that's unexplainable to people  that haven't been able to visit or have  ever been here it inspires me every day  and it's given me pretty much the life  that I have